the Joe Rogan experience Liberty
University is letting students back in
today Jesus is gonna look out for him
yeah there was a article on CNN they
were shown Liberty University opening up
its doors again students like this just
started you [ __ ] you can't just you
know where do you think we are right now
beginning yes yes you don't think you
look good till mid May listen it keeps
accelerating every day but it's
accelerating everyday that means it's at
the beginning every day there's more
cases every day there's more people
getting sick doesn't he say yesterday I
don't quote me on this he's talking
about Easter yeah because it's a very
special day to him let's see he said
it's a special day this virus doesn't
give a [ __ ] what day you think Jesus
came out of the ground this virus
doesn't give a [ __ ] and if you don't
respect it people are gonna die and
there's people like the lieutenant
governor I think is who he is of Texas
who is like we should take a risk with
older people just to get the economy
back in line people like whoa
what are you saying you think the
economy you should we should get the
economy back in line and by doing the
economy some old people are gonna have
to die
you've ready to sacrifice people for
money yeah older people would rather die
than let kovat 19 harm us economy Texas
officials said older people would rather
die this what he says lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick okay yeah and you
know he was saying that he's in that
high risk category himself because he's
70 you know as these politicians are
terrified that this is gonna lead to an
economic disaster and their names gonna
be stuck on it you know I think they
were terrified at first that they had
they had to act there to close things
down but they didn't have a plan and now
they realize like oh my god this might
have to stay locked down for a long time
what happens the economy yeah you didn't
have a plan no one had a plan so they
locked everything down and now they're
like listen this could last a long time
we got a fig we got to start the
rumblings now of getting this ball
rolling again
because if this goes six seven months
and
no one's working no one can go outside
their house for six seven months like
this is crazy
what we won't have any money and China's
gonna take over Tucker Carlson had this
whole piece he did that I saw that was
actually pretty accurate you know where
he's talking about what what could be
possible
dude like he was talking about how the
NBA did you see that whole segment where
the NBA they had said something about
China and then then you see all these
people that were praising China and
saying positive things about China what
was this what was the reason behind that
Jamie your MBA guy the GM for their
Houston Rockets tweeted like support for
Hong Kong that's right that's right
it was support for Hong Kong and then
China got pissed at that so then they
started tweeting nice things about China
and they started so at the time if that
happened that the there was like an MBA
teams in China doing games and we just
come back and then they started asking
tho them what they thought about this
and then like the Bron started
supporting China I think and then
everyone jumped on them and like like
money over people I think well you mean
that they face consequences for
supporting Hong Kong yeah well what
tucker carlson was saying in his piece
was that
imagine if that's the the whole country
like understand that like if china's the
ruler of the world of china becomes the
ruler of the world not the united states
because of something like this like this
is all really possible like the idea
that the united states is the ruler of
the world so it has to stay the ruler of
the world forever no natural disasters
disease [ __ ] asteroid impact there's
a bunch of different things that could
shift the balance of power in the world
rome used to run everything right the
you know the there's europe england the
UK you see england used to run to half
the [ __ ] planet there's a lot of
different countries that were on top of
the world that are no longer on top of
the world and we would be in a real
sticky situation if we had to live under
the same military dictatorship - china
does and the idea that we would never
have to live under that we can't wear a
mayor
well that's ridiculous because we're
human beings and other human beings are
stuck in a circumstance where they're
living under a military dictatorship so
there's no difference between them and
us other than culture and the place
where they live that that shifts things
change with natural disaster with
disease with failure of the economy with
war with all these different factors
things change and our perception much
like our perception of our society
itself it's always going to be like this
and all sudden this disease comes along
as it shuts everything down you're like
whoa that's a [ __ ] wake-up call need
to recognize that this is kind of
fragile well the whole system is fragile
if those things happen natural disaster
disease war anything catastrophic
happens the balance of power completely
shifts and who knows who's control the
survivors are under who knows who knows
how this works out
this is all real touch-and-go right now
this is real touch-and-go this is
uncharted territory where we have
slipped into a place where no one's
working and everyone's scared and the
president wants to go back to work on
Easter because it's a special day to him
and Joe Biden can't talk the guy was
running for [ __ ] president for the
Democrats can't talk did you see they
were deleted the latest [ __ ] Tim Dylan
sent me two videos he's like what the
[ __ ] is going on like he's in a
cognitive decline governor in New York
Cuomo put him in put him in coach
put him in you want it you want a guy to
run for president that makes sense you
want a guy who's an intelligent guys a
strong leader who's got a lot of
experience and press the [ __ ] out of
middle school that's the [ __ ] out of me
too what he's like
[Applause]